You're asking me to put my money into
an operation where I don't know the
founder, I don't know who's running
it. I don't know where it's run from.
All I've got is rumor and now our
Crime Bill Gates, Warren Buffett,
Charlie Munger, one of whom was calling
it a scum ball activity. The other saying,
Bill Gates saying he would
short this thing if you could,
and you're saying they're all wrong.
Yeah.
There is a shift happening right now.
A community of inclusion in
cooperation is emerging globally.
A community that's able to
provide financial services
to the 2 billion people on
Earth without a bank
account for the first time,
that's able to create new jobs for
people that were never before possible.
A community that's beginning to
transform every single industry.
So the question is,
will you join us.